le maréchal ferrant est un artisan dont
le métier consiste à ferrer les pieds
des chevaux mais aussi ceux des bovins
aujourd'hui plus rarement pratiquée
c'est un métier vieux de plus de 3000
ans il existe environ 1600 maréchaux
ferrants en france et à la réunion il
n'y en a plus qu'un seul qui faire les
bleus mais là où la rivière saint-louis
ouaki depuis notamment la grande île a
aimé vivre la main
papa la partie la nasse l'atelier pour
moi a dit modèle on a des papayes savoir
prend le métier pour l'appui trop de la
mignonne dans les concepts georges
rousse au plus connu sous le sobriquet
de ti coq a grandi avec ce métier
autrefois exercé par ses aïeux a beau
venir face à sabots pour le boeuf le n'a
pas stationner des passeurs serbe
d'où le nom n'a naturellement pas partie
henry fiable ça c'est le faire de plus
d'autorité fait ça ça c'est le plus mon
groupe et on va embêter les firmes
autorités et papa aussi et après c'est
moi
la première partie du métier consiste à
forger les faire après avoir pris les
mesures directement sur les animaux est
né dans la loge donc le faire un peu il
faut le faire il ya d'abord la faisons
un métier éprouvant physiquement qui a
évolué avec le temps
si aujourd'hui la combustion est
accélérée avec un souffleur électrique
artisanale auparavant il fallait ajouter
un soufflet et le forgeron aussi besoin
d'un assistant la france il fallait il
fallait le forgeron plus que mal il
fallait laver de masse et la même masse
est alors quand le forgeron étape est
excellent en club le tout s'est accéléré
mais cap et en même temps un avons
adapté la houlette obliger l illusion d
abbas et non pas parce que palau donc un
petit point fr te dit tout
la première partie est terminée cicor
prend la direction du lieu
d'intervention à la rivière saint-louis
près de l'ancienne balance de canne à
sucre 1 balance cocos georges a rendez
vous avec gramoune adrien un client
fidèle
et a toujours été depuis longtemps
depuis mon premier fils adam handicap de
tout engagement il fait mauvais total y
est capable aussi lié encore le battery
privé le travail est rodé et les gestes
sont précis pour la deuxième étape la
pose du fer qui servira à protéger les
ongles des bleus à protéger les enfants
mais le problème c'est que après quand
le camion l'affinement des dents
le travail terminé gramoune adrien
repart avec son taureau georges quant à
lui retournera chez lui exerçait son
autre passion la musique
car ferrer les bleus ne fait plus
aujourd'hui vivre sa famille mais il
persiste pour le plaisir et la passion
l'entente devrait comme là c'est un
plaisir pour gagner un vélo parce que
moi mais bon mon ami à l'effet de sa
voix de la musique et de